that Shermer the head coach of the
Giants raving about his rookie
quarterback who was 9 for 11 last night
against the Cincinnati Bengals for 141
yards christened so far in the preseason
25 for 33 hundred and 69 yards two
touchdowns no picks passer rating 140
point one for Daniel Jones and one last
note from Sharma he said this also last
night you can ask me all you want about
why I like Daniel Jones I think it's
time to start asking the people that
didn't like him what they think quite
frankly what's not to like about Daniel
Jones
and here we go the questions gonna
linger when will he play in the regular
season yeah it's definitely been very
impressive it really has any light
Manning again he didn't look bad last
night either I don't want that to be
noted you know it's not like he's out
there throwing lame ducks all over the
field threw a nice little ball that
could have been a touchdown pass into a
tight window the guy got hit ended up
being incomplete but daniel Jones hey
right now as it stands I was wrong and
there's no other way to say that yes I
did not love it I don't sit here and
just go oh my gosh look at his arm he's
throwing lasers all over the field and
sometimes that's what I look at it
picked number six and one but obviously
they like the psyche of the player he is
a good athlete he throws perfect spirals
every time he lets the ball out of his
hands Mike and and he and to what Pat
Shermer said that really jumps out to me
and you know where I can self scout
thyself and say I was wrong
you know but compared to him and a guy
like drew lock his Daniel Jones does
know how to play the position better
right now as far as quarterbacking in
the NFL and that does go back to David
Cutcliffe and maybe his mindset and you
get to know the guy himself when he's at
the chalkboard and in meetings and
things like that where I knew I know he
blew people away but it's been all
positive from Daniel Jones to this point
and good for him because he's silent
sending a lot of critics even like
myself and a lot of New Yorkers up here
to well remember what they were looking
for was a guy who would be able to
survive in that storm of constant
criticism and you're gonna show up on
the back pages of the tabloids and
they're gonna be talking about you on
WFAN
nationally but more importantly locally
you become an obsession and you deal
with that
and Chris the fact that he's dealt with
it so well on the front end of his
career all the criticism that emerged
getting booed at the Yankee game
everything that has come his way
he has been unflappable and that's the
kind of personality they are looking for
that will translate they believe into a
guy who can be successful even when he
has those moments of adversity because
he will come at some point how do you
deal with it and one of eli manning's
great strengths was he never got
flustered by anything that happened on
the field now Pat Shermer was also asked
this question he was asked if it's
possible that Daniel Jones could be the
week one starter sixteen days from now
at Dallas here's what Shermer said
listen carefully to what he says and
more importantly Chris what he doesn't
say question is it possible he'll start
I've said it all along Daniel when it's
time to play is going to be ready and
we're gonna continue to get him ready we
got a couple of weeks left before we
play Dallas that tells me now
I'm a little biased here because my hot
take all along has been yes I find plays
week one right but when when you're
asked is it possible that he starts week
one and that's the answer if Eli Manning
is clearly God I mean think of it there
if Bill Belichick was asked that
question about Brian Hoyer that's not
the answer you're gonna get about Brian
Hoyer Tom what are you talking about Tom
Brady's a starting quarterback so the
fact that the answer was something other
than what are you talking about Eli
Manning's the starter I think the door
is still open I may not be shown the way
but I think the door is still open it is
peculiar that he didn't just shut it
down I got a say and I didn't know about
this quote until you just read it and
said it either way but yeah just from
hearing it there you would expect the
answer to be like hey we love what
daniel Jones is doing right now
he's been phenomenal he's even exceeded
our expectations and what he's done I
mean he's really taken control of this
offense but Eli Manning's our
quarterback and he Eli's been really
good I mean that would be the answer III
would say or I would expect a lot of
head coaches to say so I'm with
it does leave a little crack in the door
there I don't think that realistically
is going to happen but I'm with you in
the fact that you yes he left us able to
debate that a little bit with the way he
said it yeah I mean and this comes at a
time when owner John Mehra has made it
clear that he's rooting for Eli Manning
just start all year long and and and
even though they say it's pat schirmer's
decision you know sometimes you got to
make the decision that the boss wants
you to make even though it's entirely
your decision you better decide to make
the decision that the person who signs
your checks is going to be happy with I
still am stunned by that comment and you
know it really gets the mind racing on
what would happen if at some point over
the next week or two they just cut you
know let's say that Pat Shermer and Dave
gentlemen bring John Mara into a film
room and they say if they even have film
rooms anymore where ever you know
wherever okay just bring the computer to
John Mayer's office with up with a
calzone and sit down and show him Daniel
Jones film and show him eli manning film
and show him some stuff from practice
and explain to him what they see in
daniel Jones I think they could be
capable of changing John Mehra's mind if
the goal is to win football games and go
with the best guy they have so who knows
what's really going on behind the scenes
and and what a strange situation that
would be to see li Manning on the bench
and you know maybe it wouldn't be on the
bench Chris I mean we don't know what's
up with Cam Newton and I don't know
whether or not the the Panthers would
even want an Eli Manning and Eli Manning
has a no-trade clause but if a Teddy
Bridgewater type injury happens in the
next week and it opens a clear
opportunity to be a team starting
quarterback all year long if Eli Manning
is looking at that versus being on the
bench to start the season if that's what
the Giants decide to do then you know
crazier things have happened in the NFL
and when Pat rumor has the opportunity
to slam the door on any talk of Danny
Jones being the starter week one that
tells me we need to keep paying
attention yeah I mean we're gonna keep
paying attention to all the things you
just said but just when you hear
everybody talk about how good I've
managed also looked at training camp and
just the look of him in the in the first
you know two preseason games of action
or three preseason games that we've seen
to this point also added to the
fact that the Mara the Mara family is
fiercely loyal especially to guys like
Eli Manning who's one of the great faces
of the franchise I mean him LT you know
my father other guys I mean Eli
Manning's gonna be at the top of all
those guys I just can't imagine the
Mehra family Steve Tisch any of them
wanting to ever see Eli Manning in
another uniform other than New York
Giants but Chris remember last year when
John Merrow was asked point-blank if he
is keeping Eli Manning on the field for
sentimental reasons he got pissed yes he
did he was mad he was almost yelling
about it and he was offended that that
question would even come up and at some
point they'll death protest too much but
it sure does feel like sentimentality is
driving it at this point and that's the
thing if look if Gettleman and Shermer
decide that it's in the best interest of
the team to go with Daniel Jones there
is a way that they can try to set the
table for John Mara to come to the
conclusion on his own that this is the
right thing to do that's how you are
yeah there's a delicate balance to get
the boss to think it's his idea but but
there is a way to do it if they feel
strongly about it and I just look at
that response from Pat Shermer last
night and I just wonder what in the hell
is going on in New York and I'm
fascinated by it and there is a chance
the Daniel Jones does give that team a
better chance to win this year and it
lays the foundation for more success I'm
a big believer in getting that guy out
there as a rookie because he's going to
hit his ceiling faster it's the best way
2021 etc I I'm with you they're there
the best way to learn and get ready for
the NFL is to get out there and play in
the NFL and and take your lumps early on
and continue to grow from there you know
and and to what you're saying to also
let's not forget this you know John Mara
you're right he did make those comments
last year it looked like he was almost
offended that that question was even
asked well he might have been offended
last year that it was even asked because
there was also nobody there that I think
was even remotely a threat to Eli
Manning as far as backup quarterbacks
were concerned I mean maybe they were
gonna play Kyle Letta but I think I'll
let I kind of showed his true colors
when he got in a cop
on the way to Giants Stadium one day so
that kind of ended that all together but
this is a different scenario you're
right with the comments between Shermer
and then we know the Mehra family
certainly signed off on drafting Daniel
Jones at number 6 - where I don't see it
happening week 1 but gosh if things got
off to a slow bad start and it's you
know 2 & 4 1 in 3 then I think there's a
very real chance that they will pull the
hook on Eli Manning and Daniel Jones
will be out there but why do you want to
let it get to that point why do you want
you know I'm saying yeah like they see
Lee Jones is better if you think he's
better why do you want to go with the
guy who's inferior and then wait until
it feels like the season is on the verge
of being lost before you trot out the
rookie that's what makes no sense to me
Chris well I I hear that but I don't
think the Giants are looking at it I
think they're looking at you know this
is first off then I don't think they'd
expect to win the Superbowl I think also
hey Eli just again would the way
everyone talks and the way I've seen it
so far how he looks yeah
maybe he's not as talented as Daniel
Jones right now that's fair he's not
Daniel Jones's got a stronger arm he's a
better athlete all those things right
now but but also you know week 1 at the
Dallas Cowboys that's a whole different
you know we've talked about how simple
pre seasons been and you know some teams
our game plan and other teams are
playing as basic as it is you know be
thrown in that fire in doubtless week
one and then also the Buffalo Bills in
week two have who have been who were one
of the three best defenses in football
last year I'm sure a little that's
coming into account to where yeah they
want to win games and maybe they feel
like Eli Manning's experience and
playing against some of these teams and
having feel for these defensive
coordinators throughout a 16-year career
that he can give them the best chance
especially early on to get off on the
right foot first regular season game
ever played at the Cowboys Stadium
Elon Dallas that was built ten days ago
he signed the wall afterward I you know
for a guy who who typically doesn't show
that side of himself he was pretty
excited about that and it's just it's
it's a tough balance it's a tough call
and it's going to be a tough transition
and Eli Manning was asked last night on
the way
the locker room if he has been told that
he will be the week one starter he said
I haven't been told and he different and
that's the guy who's kind of lost in all
this and I don't know maybe in a
roundabout way they are and and maybe
hey you know bear with me on this trying
to have the best of both worlds yeah
getting daniel Jones ready but at the
same time a little jab here a little jab
there at Eli Manning to get him pissed
off sure added up and ready to show he
still got one more good run left in him
back because yeah Jones ready in the
event that he like Manning can't get it
done right but you mean while pushing
the buttons on Eli Manning to get him
pissed off because no one's talking
about Eli Manning this preseason they're
all talking about Daniel Jeff you're
right that's a really good point Mike I
gotta say that that's Jon Gruden would
do that stuff damn when Tom Brady
started to slip they drafted Jimmy
Garoppolo and all of a sudden he started
to become this awesome player again so I
sorry I had to cut you off there but I
felt no I'm gay anytime anytime you want
to tell me I have a good point right
feel free to cut me off ok we'll always
shut up for praise
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports